how do we find all the factors of 24
it's simple we write the number as a
product of two positive numbers we have
to think of all possible combinations
though how do we write it as a product
of two numbers let me give you an
example it can be written as 1
multiplied by 24 we have written 24 as a
product of two numbers but remember we
have to think of all possible
combinations it can also be written as 2
times 12 wait it can also be written as
3 times 8 are there any more
combinations yes it can be written as 4
times 6 that's it there is no other
product of two positive numbers that
would result in 24 wait how do we know
that all products have been covered ok
so always use this logic when you are
writing a number as a product of two
numbers start off with one every number
is obviously divisible by 1 right that
product first then see if the number is
divisible by 2
which is the next natural number if yes
we write the product as we have written
it here then we move on to the next
natural number 3 is 24 divisible by 3
yes so we write the product here then
for 24 is divisible by 4 and we wrote
that product here and after 4 we have 5
is 24 divisible by 5 no it isn't so we
cannot write it as a product of 5 and
another number and the next number is 6
but 6 onwards is already covered here
that's when we know that we have covered
all possible products of two numbers the
numbers covered are in a u-shape anyway
that's all we had to do what are the
factors of 24 then all these numbers
individually are the factors of 24 we
can say that the factors of 24 are 1 2 3
4 say
eight 12 and 24v right the number as all
possible products of two numbers and
then each of the numbers become a factor
of that number
let's try finding the factors of another
number we need to find all the factors
of 30 to do that all we have to do is
write 30 as all possible products of two
numbers I will be telling you the answer
in some time meanwhile you can try
writing down the combinations in your
notebook we can start off with the
number 1 30 can be written as 1
multiplied by 30 this is the simplest
and the most obvious combination one is
always a factor of all numbers then we
move on to 2 is 30 divisible by 2 yes
and the product can be written as 2
multiplied by 15 is 30 divisible by 3
yes the product can be written as 3
multiplied by 10 is 30 divisible by 4 no
it isn't so we cannot write a product
with 4 as one of the numbers what about
5 yes 30 is divisible by 5 and the
product can be written as 5 multiplied
by 6 the next number is 6 which is
already covered here and the numbers
after 6 are covered here that's when we
know that we have exhausted all
possibilities these are the only four
ways in which we can write 30 as a
product of two numbers so we can say
that these eight numbers individually
are the factors of 30 the factors are 1
2 3 5 6 10 15 and 30 how can we define
factors then well the factors of a
number are basically exact divisors of
that number